talk about putting stuff in perspective
do you even remember what was going on
last week
in 2020 what the hell is up with you we
get it
you want a one up 1349 a.d with their
black plague
you want to beat the crap out of 536 a.d
with its cold and deadly dark ages
you want to make 1933 or 1918 appear
quaint
but please we beg of you can you cut us
a break for a few days please
we get it you suck you're the worst
we'll make you a trophy
worst year ever okay so as you already
know the president and the first lady
tested positive for the coronavirus
our thoughts are with them and with
everyone battling this virus as we hope
for a speedy recovery
here's white house chief of staff mark
meadows friday
we address this this battle together as
a nation together
and the american people can rest assured
that
we have a president that is
not only on the job will remain on the
job in true fashion he's probably
critiquing the way that i'm answering
these questions
yay you're right he is so the president
remains
on the job in quarantine but the
election is a month away
and this will no doubt impact the weeks
ahead how does it affect the campaign
trail for both candidates what about the
next debates or the supreme court
i don't care that much we have more than
enough time to yak about that crap
and believe me we will but first we
should hope for the best for our
president his wife our country
and here are my suggestions to weather
this latest news
stay off social media please because we
know everything today is political
worse in this new era people who
disagree with you thanks to the media
see you as evil and will take pleasure
in this news it's ironic that people who
preach empathy have almost none of it
in their backpacks even so-called civil
bold-faced names are morphing into giddy
ghouls
so if anyone says something to you that
you find in bad taste
don't react simply say this can we try
to put aside this partisanship as our
president and our first lady
fight a potentially deadly disease so
let's just try to be americans
not republicans or democrats for maybe a
day or two
because the fate of our country depends
on it in short take the high road
there aren't a lot of them left